the Joe Rogan experience there's also
these traps that people sort of
establish in their own mind of giving
themselves excuses or giving themselves
in unsurmountable obstacles
insurmountable victim mentality yeah
somebody else's fault it's my sellers
fault it's the system's fault yeah those
people are sinking I feel bad for them I
want to shake them out of it and say
actually you can get out of it you just
have to stop thinking it's everybody's
alter the perspective yeah it's so
difficult for people to do it's one of
the most difficult things for people to
do is to change the way they approach
approach reality itself at the end of
the day I do think even despite what I
said earlier life is really a
single-player game it's all going on in
your head you know whatever you think
you believe will very much shape your
reality both from what risks you take
and what actions you perform but also
just everyday experience of reality if
you're walking down the street and
you're judging everyone you're like I
don't like that person because their
skin color I don't like that she's she's
not attractive that guy's fat this
person's a loser oh who put this in my
way you know the more you judge the more
you're gonna separate yourself and
you'll feel good for an instant because
you'll feel good about yourself I'm
better than that but then you're gonna
feel lonely and then you're just gonna
see negativity everywhere the world just
reflects your own feelings back at you
reality is neutral reality has no
judgments to a tree there's no concept
of right or wrong or good or bad right
you're born you have a whole set of
sensory experiences and stimulations and
lights and colors and sounds and then
you die yeah and how you choose to
interpret that is up to you you do have
that choice so this is what I meant that
happiness is a choice if you believe
it's the choice then you can start
working on it and I can't tell you how
to find it because use your own
conditionings that are making you
unhappy so you have to uncondition
yourself it's just like I can't fix your
eating habits for you can give some
general guidelines but you got to go
through the hard habit-forming of how to
eat right but you have to believe it's
possible and it is absolutely possible I
was miserable I'm happy as a clam it's
not just the money I got there before
the money you got happy before the money
mostly yeah how did you get happy before
the money I started getting older you
know I just realized like life is short
I'm gonna die
again try right right in my ways yeah
well Confucius had a great saying that
you know every man has two lives and the
second starts when he realizes he has
just one Wow and I read that it was one
of those book dropping lines you know
it's like mic drop Confucius had a lot
of mic drops that's a crazy one that was
a great one or another one is next time
you get sick you know because everybody
gets sick every now and then it's like a
happy person once ten thousand things a
sick person just wants one thing right
so it's your it's your unlimited desires
that are clouding your peace your
happiness have desires
you're a biological creature that stands
up and says I can do something I I move
I resist I live but just be very careful
of your desires this is the oldest most
trite wisdom desire is suffering that's
what it means right every desire you
have is an access where you will suffer
so just don't focus on more than one
desire at a time the universe is rigged
in such a way that if you just want one
thing and you focus on that you'll get
it but everything else you gotta let go
did you make a gradual shift to
happiness or was it a radical change
it's ongoing its gradual every day
you're happier today than you were a
month ago yeah allegedly yeah yeah I'm
very happy these days deliriously so
it's actually hard for me to hang out
with normal people oh really so you
you've made a significant shift over the
period of like how many years about
eight years eight years
yeah Wow and is this something that
you've pursued through certain books or
is it just like you you've made an
understanding or gained an understanding
in your own mind and then started
pursuing it based on that understanding
yeah it's very very personal it's
basically you have to decide it's a
priority and then I tried every hack I
possibly could I used to you know I
tried all the I tried meditation I tried
witnessing you know I even tried a
missus all right just to see what it
would feel like how did it feel it was
it turned me from a pessimist to an
optimist but I didn't like the physical
side effects nor did I want to be in a
drug for sustained basis mmm so I
dropped it and I thought it'd turn you
into an opt
yes at the time I used to be a pessimist
yeah I started doing things like I would
start looking at the you know in every
moment and everything that happens you
can look on the bright side of something
right and so I used to do that forcibly
and then I trained it until I became
second nature so for example like a
friend of my wife's was over and she
when we were dating and she did all
these photos she took like hundreds of
photos and then she sends them all to us
and my immediate reaction was like why
are you dumping hundreds of photos on my
phone I don't need hundreds of photos
have some judgment that's my immediate
reaction and then I could say actually
how nice of her she sent me hundreds of
photos I can pick the one that I like
right there are two ways of seeing
almost everything there are few things
that are like high suffering so you
can't do that other than just saying
well this is a teacher right but I
slowly work through every negative
judgment that I had until I saw the
positive and not second nature to me I
also realized that like what you want is
you want to clear minds you want to let
go of thoughts happy thoughts disappear
out ahead automatically very easy to let
go of them negative thoughts linger so
if you interpret the negative the
positive and everything very quickly you
let it go right you let it go much
faster okay simple hacks get more
sunlight right learn to smile more learn
to hug more these things actually
released serotonin in Reverse they
aren't just outward signals of being
happy they're actually feedback loops to
being happy spend more time in nature
you know these are obvious watch your
mind watch your mind all day long watch
what it does not judge it and I try to
control it but you can meditate 24/7
meditation is not a sit down close your
eyes activity meditation is just
basically watching your own thoughts
like you would watch anything else in
the outside world and say why am I
having that thought does that serve me
anymore is that conditioning from when I
was 10 years old like for example I'm
getting ready for this podcast you got
ready
I didn't all right good I did but I did
I did I couldn't help it and what
happened was the few days leading up to
this my mind was just running and
normally my mind is pretty calm it was
just running and running and running and
every thought I would have
I would imagine me saying it to you my
brain couldn't help but rehearse what
what is doing is just rehearsing all the
time to talk to you and
I was even rehearsing rehearsed telling
you about the rehearsal mmm is all play
better games and I was just like shut up
stop it what is going on and it took me
a while to figure out oh yeah you know
what it is when I was a kid in Queens
and I had no money and I had nothing and
I needed to save myself
the way I got out was by sounding smart
not being smart sounding smart that was
the skill I perfected so I am hardwired
to always rehearse things so I will
sound smart it's a disease it keeps me
from being happy so but when you see
that when you realize that when you
understand something then it naturally
calms you down so after that I stopped
rehearsing as much Wow but it's still a
trained habit that is a really
interesting point that you want to sound
smart that that many people do that and
especially young people when you see
someone who is smart or someone who
appears smart they say smart things you
kind of want to sound smart I want
people to think about me the same way I
think about that person that is my
disease that isn't my feeling is what
clutters my mind I the thing I have to
ask myself now is if I can would I still
be interested in learning this thing if
I couldn't ever tell anybody about it
that's how I know it's real that's how I
know it's something I actually want
that's a common thing though I know I
suffered from that when I was young the
desire to sound smart that's it's very
it's very common well all of us start
out you know every everything you're the
winner now in your life you were to lose
it's because you were a loser at some
point right if if you had gotten all the
girls if you had all the money if you
had everything you want you were
good-looking and in junior high or high
school you wouldn't have done anything
with your life mm-hmm and you would have
peaked early it's like the Bruce
Springsteen glory days song right you're
too married your high school sweetheart
you'd be living in your hometown you
know you'd be a manager at the local
McDonald's whatever the dream job you
had thank God we didn't all get what we
wanted when we were young right or we
would be trapped in that so you have to
be able to break out of where you came
from